La première fois que j'ai entendu parler de la communauté chrétienne des Coptes,
c'était en 2009,
quand les autorités égyptiennes, sous le régime de Hosni Mubarak,
ont décidé d'abattre 300 000 cochons en raison du virus H1N1.
Ce sont des éleveurs de cochons.
Leurs cochons et autres animaux sont nourris avec les déchets organiques
qu'ils ramassent quotidiennement.
Cet événement a tué leur gagne-pain.
A ma première visite à Manshiyat Naser, j'étais comme dans un labyrinthe.
Je cherchais le monastère Saint Simon au sommet du Mont Mokattam.
Vous allez à droite, tout droit, de nouveau à droite puis à gauche
pour atteindre le sommet.
Mais pour y arriver, il faut éviter les camions débordant de déchets
et slalomer entre les tuk-tuks,
les véhicules les plus rapides pour se déplacer dans le quartier.
L'odeur des poubelles sorties de ces camions était intense
et le fort bruit du trafic dominait tout le reste.
Ajoutez-y le vacarme des broyeurs dans ces entrepôts le long de la rue.
De l'extérieur, cela semble chaotique mais tout est parfaitement organisé.
Les Zaraeebs, c'est le nom qu'ils se sont donné,
cela signifie éleveurs de cochons.
Ils ramassent les poubelles du Caire
et les trient dans leur quartier depuis des décennies.
Ils ont mis en place un des systèmes
de recyclage les plus efficaces et les plus rentables au niveau mondial.
Pourtant, l'endroit est perçu comme sale, marginalisé et isolé,
du fait de son association aux déchets.
Mon idée initiale était de créer une œuvre anamorphique,
une œuvre visible uniquement depuis un certain point de vue.
C'était un défi artistique que de peindre sur plusieurs immeubles
et que ce ne soit pleinement visible que d'un endroit sur le Mont Mokattam.
Le Mont Mokattam est la fierté de la communauté.
Ils y ont bâti le monastère Saint Simon,
une église rupestre de 10 000 places creusée à même la montagne.
La première fois que je me suis tenu sur la montagne
et que j'ai regardé le quartier,
je me suis demandé comment j'allais convaincre les propriétaires
de me laisser peindre leurs immeubles.
Puis Magd est arrivé.
Magd est un guide de l'église.
Il m'a dit que la seule personne que je devais convaincre était le père Samaan,
le chef de la communauté.
Mais pour convaincre le père Samaan, je devais convaincre Mario,
un artiste polonais habitant au Caire depuis 20 ans
qui a créé toutes les œuvres de l'église rupestre.
Je lui suis reconnaissant, il était la clé du projet.
Il m'a obtenu un entretien avec le père Samaan
qui, étonnamment, a adoré l'idée.
Il m'a demandé où j'avais déjà peint
et comment j'allais procéder.
Il s'inquiétait surtout de ce que j'allais écrire.
Dans chacune de mes œuvres, j'écris un message
avec mon style de calligraphie arabe.
Je m'assure que ces messages soient en adéquation avec le lieu,
tout en restant universels,
pour que tout le monde soit concerné.
Pour Manshiyat Naser,
j'ai décidé d'écrire en arabe les mots de Saint Athanase d'Alexandrie,
un évêque copte du IIIème siècle
qui a dit : (arabe),
ce qui signifie :
« Quiconque voulant voir clairement la lumière du soleil
doit d'abord se frotter les yeux. »
C'était très important pour moi
que la communauté se sente liée à ces mots.
Pour moi, cette citation reflétait parfaitement l'esprit du projet.
Le père Samaan a donné sa bénédiction pour le projet
et son approbation a rallié tous les résidents.
Des centaines de litres de peinture, une dizaine d'élévateurs manuels,
plusieurs allers-retours au Caire,
une solide équipe venant de France, d'Afrique du Nord,
du Moyen-Orient et des États-Unis,
et après un an de préparation et de logistique, nous y voici,
mon équipe et quelques membres de la communauté locale,
créant une œuvre s'étendant sur plus de 50 immeubles,
certains garnissant la calligraphie que je trace
avec de la couleur.
Du bleu ici, du jaune là, de l'orange là-bas.
D'autres portant des sacs de sable
et les amenant sur le toit des immeubles
pour maintenir ces élévateurs,
d'autre encore montant et démontant ces élévateurs
pour les passer d'immeuble en immeuble.
Au début du projet,
j'avais numéroté ces immeubles sur mon croquis,
il n'y avait pas d'interaction avec la communauté.
Les gens ne comprenaient pas l'intérêt.
Mais rapidement, ces numéros d'immeubles sont devenus des noms de famille.
Le premier immeuble était la maison de l'oncle Ibrahim.
L'oncle Ibrahim est très joyeux,
toujours en train de chanter et de blaguer,
et ses enfants m'ont sauvé de son taureau
qui voulait m'attaquer au quatrième étage.
(Rires)
Le taureau m'a vu depuis la fenêtre et est sorti sur le balcon.
Ouais.
L'oncle Ibrahim était toujours sur le balcon
et me parlait quand je peignais.
Je me souviens qu'il m'a dit ne pas être allé sur la montagne depuis 10 ans
et qu'il n'avait jamais de congés.
S'il arrêtait de travailler, qui arrêterait les déchets ?
Étonnamment, à la fin du projet,
il est venu sur la montagne pour voir l’œuvre.
Il était très fier de voir sa maison peinte
et il disait que ce projet était un projet de paix et --
pardon --
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Il disait que c'était un projet de paix et d'unité
et qu'il réunissait les gens.
Sa perception du projet a changé
et ma perception de la communauté et de ce qu'ils font
a aussi changé.
Tous ces déchets qui dégoûtent tout le monde, ce n'est pas à eux.
C'est juste leur travail.
Ils ne vivent pas dans les poubelles mais ils vivent des poubelles.
Je me suis remis en question et me suis demandé
quel était le vrai objectif de ce projet.
Il n'était pas question d'embellir un endroit en y apportant de l'art.
Il était question de changer les perceptions
et de créer un dialogue
sur les liens avec des communautés qui nous sont inconnues.
Jour après jour,
le cercle calligraphique prenait forme
et nous avions hâte de revenir sur la montagne pour regarder l’œuvre.
Me tenir à cet endroit précis tous les jours m'a fait réaliser
le symbolisme derrière cette œuvre anamorphique.
Si vous voulez voir le vrai visage de quelqu'un,
vous devez changer de point de vue.
Il y a eu des doutes et des difficultés,
des peurs et du stress.
C'était dur de travailler dans ces environnements,
peindre avec des cochons dans le dos
ou escalader un tas d'ordures pour monter sur l'élévateur.
Mais nous avons dépassé le vertige, les oscillations des élévateurs,
la forte odeur
et le stress de ne pas finir dans les temps.
Mais la gentillesse de ces personnes nous a fait tout oublier.
L'immeuble n°3 était la maison de l'oncle Bakheet et de la tante Fareeda.
En égyptien, il y a cette expression : « Ahsen Nas »,
« les meilleures personnes ».
C'étaient eux.
Nous prenions notre pause devant chez eux
et tous les enfants du quartier
se joignaient à nous.
J'étais impressionné et émerveillé par les enfants de Manshiyat Naser.
Les premiers jours, ils refusaient tout ce que nous leur proposions,
même à manger ou à boire.
J'ai demandé pourquoi à tante Fareeda.
Elle m'a dit qu'ils apprenaient aux enfants à refuser
tout ce qui venait d'un inconnu
car cette personne pourrait en avoir plus besoin qu'eux.
A ce moment-là, j'ai réalisé
que la communauté des Zaraeebs était idéale
pour parler de perception.
Nous devons remettre en question nos idées reçues
et le jugement que nous avons, en tant que société,
sur ces communautés à cause de leurs différences.
Je me souviens que nous avons pris du retard chez l'oncle Ibrahim
quand ses cochons, élevés sur le toit,
mangeaient les sacs de sable maintenant l'élévateur.
(Rires)
La maison de l'oncle Bakheet et la tante Fareeda
était un lieu de rendez-vous.
Tout le monde s'y réunissait.
C'est ce que voulait dire l'oncle Ibrahim
quand il a parlé de projet de paix et d'unité
car j'ai vraiment vu ces gens se réunir.
Tout le monde nous félicitait avec un sourire et un verre
ou en nous invitant à déjeuner chez eux.
Parfois, vous êtes au premier étage d'un immeuble
et quelqu'un ouvre sa fenêtre et vous offre du thé.
Cela se reproduit au deuxième étage.
Et ainsi de suite jusqu'au toit.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je n'ai jamais bu autant de thé qu'en Égypte.
(Rires)
Pour être honnête, nous aurions pu finir plus tôt
mais cela nous a pris 3 semaines à cause de toutes ces pauses thé.
(Rires)
En Égypte, ils ont une autre expression : « Nawartouna »,
« Tu nous as apporté la lumière ».
A Manshiyat Naser, ils nous disaient toujours cela.
La calligraphie --
pour la calligraphie, j'ai utilisé une peinture blanche luminescente,
donc à la fin du projet, nous avons loué des projecteurs de lumière noire,
avons éclairé tout le quartier
et surpris tout le monde.
Nous voulions leur dire
que c'était eux qui nous avaient apporté la lumière.
(Applaudissements)
La communauté des Zareebs est forte, honnête, travailleuse
et connaît sa valeur.
Les gens du Caire les appellent « Zabaleen »,
« le peuple des poubelles »,
mais, ironiquement, le peuple de Manshiyat Naser
appelle les gens du Caire
aussi « Zabaleen », puisqu'ils produisent les déchets, pas eux.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Nous voulions laisser quelque chose à la communauté
mais nous sommes repartis avec quelque chose dans nos vies.
Le projet d'art n'était qu'un prétexte
à une expérience humaine extraordinaire.
A un moment, l’œuvre disparaîtra
car quelqu'un construit un deuxième étage
devant la maison d'oncle Ibrahim,
recouvrant une partie de la peinture,
je devrais peut-être y retourner et repeindre.
(Rires)
C'était pour l'expérience,
pour l'histoire,
pour l'instant.
Des rues du quartier,
la peinture apparaît en fragments,
isolés les uns les autres,
distincts.
Mais connectés avec la calligraphie,
ils révèlent le puissant message auquel nous devrions tous réfléchir
avant de juger quelqu'un.
Quiconque voulant voir clairement la lumière du soleil
doit d'abord se frotter les yeux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)